Well, we're going to also say, since we're from New York,
we're going to call her. Although it's spelled Houston,
we're going to call her Whitney house than strictly house Whitney house.
Whitney house in Houston started her modeling career when she was 16.
Here's the difference between America and Canada?
Our most favorite or most famous crack addict is Whitney Houston.
One of the greatest cigarettes to ever grace the earth in all of
history.
And Canada's most famous crack user is a Toronto mayor,
Rob Ford.
And that's should go more to tell you that because we're just better at
everything. Even our crack is better.
Of emotional stress. Yeah. Okay. My eating habits awful.
Quit the dying crack rehab phase. First of all,
let's get one straight. Exactly cheap Coke.
I make too much money to ever crack.
Let's get that straight exactly to crack is whack.
So I still do this day and like do not lack.
The girl is an amazing singer. Um, same with Amy Winehouse.
The voices are beautiful, but it just seems like, yeah,
a lot of that talent up there, it just musically. I mean,
they just get in drugs and alcohol.
I think it's a lot of the lifestyle is a big part of it, I think.
And I think ma do you think maybe just cause this is a cosmic joke does life
that when you're given that much of a talent, there's also an equally, an equal,
but opposite blind spot. And that blind spot was for some good old,
big fat jailhouse, former boy band.
Good old Dick, Dick Bobby Brown, Bobby Brown, Dick.
Must've been stupid. They famous. Yeah.
He's dancing mind do while the eighties were wild where you could just wear a
space suit. You're just good. And a flat top because I mean, you're,
everyone's outfit in the eighties when they were on stage,
looked like they were in space X and they were going to Mars. Yeah.
They were going to Mars, but yeah, they're all, it's all Elon Musk stuff.
[Inaudible].
He had SIG God did not bless us with that. It did it pledged for that.
And are we going to get limited or no ads?
Because we sang a cover because they're going to listen to it.
And they won't even recognize that it was her song because we sounded so
banking.
Imagine being on that set and just getting to see the magic work and imagine
just getting able to being able to kiss Kevin Costner and his scene. I mean,
that's the thing. I mean, Kevin Costner, he was.
In dances with wolves.
With Dolly Parton, 1970s, Dolly Parton. I first girl,
I ever jerked off till she had, she was the original, like big Natty,
big Natty celebrity. And those were nannies, right? Yeah. Well,
here's a fun fact. Saddam Hussein love Whitney Houston's rendition. Uh,
so much that he used it in Arabic version of IO.
I will always love you as his re-election campaign theme. So he used,
I will always love you and Arabic as his reelection campaign theme,
Saddam Hussein, right? Everyone. Like I agree with you,
people aren't going to live anyway. It's like, if you want to do some drugs and,
and go out of 48, that's your business right there. She gave the world her gift,
like you said, well, what else do you want me to?
What else do you want this lady to do?
Then auto tune came out and all these AI robots, you know, copying her voice,
people copied her style. What else do you want to do? I mean,
you gave us your angelic gorgeous, beautiful voice. You know, I have t-shirts,
I'll get a Whitney Houston tattoo. I don't give a. It's like,
if you went on a bathtub before 50, I mean, most of them don't make it,
you know, Prince Michael Jackson, Whitney. It's like what? It's like,
it's like seeing a tall, older person, you know, if you don't,
it doesn't happen.
You don't really see rock stars living into their seventies or eighties.
There's a few, but most of them go out early and it's sad,
but it's just kind of par for the course. I think, you know, I mean,
if you're going to die in a bath, Tom, you want to die in a first rate bathtub.
I mean dying in the Beverly Hills hotel bathtub beats the out of dying
at a Ramada in bathtub, in Uniontown, Pennsylvania,
which is how I'm going to die, which is how you're going to die.
What a soul Joel gig. We really hope you enjoyed that episode.
Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate and review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patrion.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really.
Wild.